speaking of powerful
powerful women of color this
is my rent room welcome to my right room
this is where i can share my thoughts on
everything
a tv professional want to buy a boom or
a lapel mic
lazy why did your f why does your room
look like the pants 80s people worked
out in
yeah also why are you wearing the 80s
pants that people worked out in yeah
so oh by the way this is the title of
the videos let's call it what it is
white supremacy we get through one month
without having to see this dumb
dressed like a fly girl no you can't
jesus
christ this is where i can share my
thoughts on everything that's happening
and she dresses more like steve harvey
well then let's be real
a lot has been happening honestly a
little too much so i haven't been on the
air in a year and
thank god it's been pretty dope it's
been wonderful it's one of one of the
best things in the world actually not
having you
she really hasn't been on the air for a
year wow it's been that long it's so
successful royce
see the thing is like she's such a
success did jimmy fallon take a year off
that
well no they couldn't do jimmy kimmel
take care that would be unthinkable did
stephen colbert take a year off
no no they they mostly did shows from
their home okay
but no lily they they're they're
retooling because it's gonna be
let me tell you something when she gets
back on tv crazy
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be lit
she's live
for a [ __ ] year nobody else's even
with covid
and no live audience these [ __ ]
are still doing shows
season one was taped in advance entirely
we thought we were so smart we're like
we'll bang this evergreen content we can
air it whatever
now you thought you were smart you
didn't think you were smart the reason
that they filmed it
all in advance was because they had no
faith in your show and a lot of your
episodes didn't
air let's not forget that a lot of our
episodes didn't make air
yeah and they had to film them in
advance because they had the remember
they had to put in the laughter
laugh tracks afterwards well and they
also had to film them in advance because
it's a lot cheaper to get one studio to
audience in and bang out three or four
episodes
in one day as opposed to doing uh you
know
cause i know you remember when uh david
letterman when he went over to cbs it
was one of the biggest entertainment
stories in history
i mean it was massive when letterman
left nbc
and he went to cbs and if you guys um
remember when letterman first went over
to cbs
they kept it very small they kept it
very low key
and they would bring in these audiences
in secret next to a subway
and they would bang out like 10 episodes
in one shot and then edit them and add
laughter and all that
no wait i'm sorry that's not now that i
remember uh they bought the ed
sullivan theater and going to see david
letterman live
became one of the biggest broadway draws
in history for two decades sorry lily i
got you confused with david letterman
yeah but did you have to use the
bathroom at a subway at david studio no
they had
gorgeous bathrooms in the ed sullivan
theater that were a part of history
okay bathrooms that sammy davis jr used
to throw up in
okay it'll always make sense i mean
it's always going to be relatable movie
theaters and vacations like knowing what
your friends chins look like
you're so smart and then a literal
global pandemic kit and i was the you
could just say global pandemic you don't
have to say a literal one when you
mention it she does to appeal to the
youth
oh only show that had a live audience
that's my luck you like my luck
and literally every day in season one i
would get a million tweets that said
why do you have a live audience that
room is terrible
the whole time she's talking i just feel
like we're waiting on our uh
on our vests and our guns for laser tag
like we're in that waiting room where
you're like
okay bring your vest up to the front
give them to the next group
you know what it looks like you know the
80s cafe from back to the future too
yes that's what it looks like you must
try the hot plate special yeah where are
you [ __ ] doing this video from the
max
it's the max that's what it looks like
get a million tweets that said why do
you have well if that was the case i
wish it was dust and diamond now
[Laughter]
a live audience why are you not wearing
a mask and i'm just like because
wait a minute royce dustin diamond got
stabbed and he has stage four cancer
right now does he swear to god
yeah he went to the hospital with a body
apparently runs in his family and he
went and he has stage four cancer
throat cancer i think damn that's wrong
pretty bad now all these people from say
by the way that weren't talking to him
we're all like
we're with you diamond we're with you
bud we love you that's right because
they all hate them
after that yeah every day in season one
i would get a million tweets that said
why do you have a lot i would have mad
props if just one of the old cast
members was like yeah well that's what
you get for writing a tell-all
and it was actually tori that's going to
do it
no it would be um what's-her-face the
scientologist one that was on the show
remedy uh sadonika says is is lily sing
on the set of paula abdul's opposites
attract video
is there a cartoon cat there this really
does and it's blurry looking too so it
really looks like
found footage why are you not wearing a
mask and i'm just like because that's
2019 really okay if you look closely you
can tell because she doesn't have all
the stress wrinkles yet yeah
all right right there i filmed those
episodes back in 2019 when the only
people wearing masks were robbers and
jim carreys
robbers
and jim carrey was jim carrey wearing
him
when's the last time jim carrey wore the
mask in the movie the mask was the 90s
right
it's topical like a good joke would have
been like
yeah i i haven't been that's those were
old episodes this footage back then
the only people wearing masks were
antifa
and something oh asian people on an
airplane
they were they really were [ __ ]
trendsetters
smoking wait can we say that dude
remember that remember in the membership
carrying the mask and he was like shhh
smoking she's literally lois griffin
smoking she's literally lois griffin
is smoking i remember that
smoking smoking all right
all right we heard you
she is stupid
gary smoking wait can we say that is
that copyright
no i still don't know how the show works
but you know what despite all the
tragedy i did get to a place where i
found 2020 to be quite bittersweet
you know after i was done all the crying
i decided let's try optimism yeah you
found a place all right back on youtube
yep welcome back to the dregs
welcome back to being with the no brand
no name [ __ ] feels good donut
pandemic for me to learn about work-life
balance did you know apparently there's
this meal in the middle of a day called
lunch
i
is she on meth she's she you know what
she is
she's like the wacky annoying girlfriend
that was given
way too much not only given too much
but also too many guys fake laughed at
her
because they wanted to [ __ ] her yeah
it's unearned confident like just
unearned confidence issues but i mean
she wow me but a lot of her fans even
are girls and young people like she was
given this [ __ ] thing and it's like
she reminds me of when somebody goes oh
man you're going to meet my girlfriend
tonight oh my god you're going to love
her she's so funny she's so funny
bro she's the funniest girl i've ever
met you're like i have a feeling
that i'm not going to find her as funny
as you and then they show up and they're
like this one they're just all wacky and
you're like
is she okay is she on drugs
i never heard people and i finally
re-examined my relationship with social
media yeah it turns out we were friends
without benefits so during quarantine i
deleted it off my phone bye
yeah you know why you deleted it off
your phone lily do you want the real
reason you deleted social media off your
phone they called lunch i know what
happened
without benefits so during quarantine i
deleted it off my phone you want to know
why you deleted it off your phone
because people caught you stealing jokes
they called you out on it
repeatedly audience members were that
been to your show were saying what a
fake
you were saying you weren't funny people
were pointing out that oh my god
these rotten tomatoes reviews seem kind
of fake you were getting bombarded by
everybody
being told that you're terrible yeah
listen you
you left social media for the same
reason anybody leaves social media
because the haters um
outnumbered the people who actually like
you that's the only reason to delete
social media
everyone has people that hate them if
you go up if you keep moving up a level
people are going to hate you right like
there's people that hate me
but the ratio of people that like me on
social media to the ones that hate me
is such that all i have to do is mute a
couple dozen people
and then i'm back to normal whereas with
you eighty percent of the people who
were tagging you
probably hated your see it's easy to get
like that's the one thing when they go
like oh i was the haters that i stopped
doing social media and you go
but you shouldn't have that many hater
like your haters
should never have a ratio of four to one
against the people that actually like
you
so if the haters are just all you see
non-stop then that means you suck and
that's why you leave
social media as opposed to just i just
got to mute some people once in a while
that guy's annoying
and that's why you left you left because
you were run off social media
and like roy said too because you got
caught stealing jokes because every time
you made a joke on social media it was
stolen from some
smaller twitter account i realized that
when i'm
mindlessly scrolling through social
media the entire world seems a lot worse
than it actually is
and this became very apparent to me
during the black lives matter protest
here we go
here we go you ready here it comes you
ready
i'd be on twitter and i'd see people
fighting and being mean
and division and once i deleted social
media and i went to a protest in real
life it was actually beautiful
yes because when you went to the protest
in real life
you were in an echo chamber surrounded
by everyone that thought like you
obviously it's going to be lovely for
you isn't it everyone was getting along
you're giving each other water giving
each other snacks
standing together for something because
you didn't have any food there okay but
you didn't have any
water there but using that metric of
everyone's so nice and everyone's
getting along
if you if you go to a white
meeting everyone's nice to each other
they give each other water water and
they all get along
or milk or milk out of their eyes they
all get along
if you go to any group of people that
are like-minded
they're going to get along they're all
gonna get along and like go to a comic
convention
everyone's gonna get all along it's fine
i mean that's that's how it is it's not
she's implying that black lives matter
little groups hey i tell you what did
you go to the one in minneapolis
when they burned the city down was that
a fun one
beautiful everyone was getting along
you're giving each other water giving
each other snacks standing together for
something they really believed in and
you just never saw that online
social media will give you 800 ways to
look like a bratz doll but not one
glimpse of real human connection and if
i can be real right now we need all the
positivity we can get
okay so you're about to say something
that's positive about all people right
you know you know who's always saying
like let's stop with the negative
let's start with the positivity and
stuff
hateable people right it's it's the same
thing
people that go let's all focus on
positivity it's because you're getting
bombarded with negativity
it's like when somebody's a piece of
[ __ ] and they go well we don't have to
sit here and focus on the past all the
time
the only people that don't want to focus
on the past are people that have been
really shitty in their past
yeah oh what are we going to worry about
the the past all the time
well i don't know because i'm proud of
my past maybe you don't want to talk
about the past
so yeah she wants to be all miss
positive and it's like yeah because
negativity always results in people
making fun of your shitty show
especially with the recent news of
everything that has gone down at the
capitol
and i'm going to be honest i have lost
all patience for anyone that is still
questioning privilege
bipolar people are always told that
they're justified outraged positivity
it's problematic it is a huge
issue positive kaepernick took a knee
during the anther and peaceful protest
he was told that he's disrespecting
america and i would bet money that those
same people that made that critique are
the ones that broke into the capital
and replaced the american flag with a
confederate flag a flag that literally
broke america apart kaepernick disrupted
a football game and was called a traitor
and these people are literally
disrupting democracy no no no no pause
nobody ever look first of all you're
dumb
the argument for most of us was never
that
uh kaepernick was a traitor that he like
yeah okay you can find
on the internet that want to suck cops
dicks and are like you're being
disrespectful
to all our boys who died for that plague
but most of us lily thought that that
guy was
that those people were see what most of
us took exception with was the fact that
this person was choosing their job to be
the place
where they draw a line in the sand and
protest when they're making millions of
dollars while other people
are struggling to bring food home from
their table see
lilly there are people out there who
could possibly potentially lose
their shitty 26 thousand dollar a year
job
because they hung up a pro trump thing
in their cubicle
and they're gonna get fired for it see
lily a lot of us believe
that at work is not necessarily the
place
to start protests and be a distraction
from work
so no not everybody thought he's a
traitor and should be deported
most of us were just like does this
[ __ ] really have to be on the clock
and take a knee on national television
when he's representing his team
and representing his organization like
that that was the problem i think lily
the problem is that
the military is one of the single
biggest [ __ ] boosters of the nfl
in existence they give them millions
upon millions of dollars
so if you were a football player and
let's say
uh pepsi decides we're going to give the
nfl a billion dollars over 10 years
and then you should start cutting all
these interviews off the field saying
well i think pepsi [ __ ] sucks i think
it's piss i drink coca-cola
i wouldn't [ __ ] you couldn't put a
gun in my face and make me drink pepsi
that's how [ __ ] that stuff is
you would get in trouble right like
would you not have nfl people going
first look we're gonna find you dude you
can't like they're giving us a lot of
[ __ ] money
so i i hate this argument that you have
to be a white
to find what colin kaepernick did
distasteful i wouldn't care if every
colin kaepernick interview off the field
was him saying we got to do something
about police this is [ __ ]
you know what every time i got to go out
on that field and [ __ ] stand for the
national anthem
it makes me [ __ ] sick but i got to do
it because it's my job
but he didn't do that he wanted to he
chose to blow up his nfl career
to exchange it for another career lily
stop
stop being a [ __ ] liar plus didn't
she just say she was about positivity
like
yeah two seconds ago not for white
people though call it what it is
okay it was never about respecting or
disrespecting america
it was always about whites and that is
not my opinion
it is a fact i was really no that is
your opinion that is your opinion
you literally it's not a fact she
actually started it with
this is my opinion and then ended it
with that's a fact
she not only did she actually said and
look that's just my opinion but i think
that blah blah blah
and that's a fact that's the definition
of an opinion
you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's great it's nose and not a it was
about white
okay so when they were burning down
[ __ ] when they were burning down
small businesses and they were killing
david dorn
was that [ __ ] about black power
that's a fact when they killed david
dorn it was about black power
that's a fact it's a it's not a fact
it's your opinion
do you think that the 70 million people
that voted for trump
were all white supremacists yes [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no they weren't they were a lot of them
weren't even white
what the [ __ ] this mentality that's a
fact
no it's not this country is not overrun
with white supremacist
that is some sort of weird [ __ ]
fallacy that's been putting out there
and then trying to normalize it that
this country's run by white
it's not this country is a bunch of
people and the problem is is that
for how many years you isolated and
overlooked and made the people in the
middle of the country feel like
dumb hillbilly hicks and made them feel
small
and they didn't care if you were black
they didn't care if you were white or
chinese
or anything they didn't [ __ ] care
they just wanted their jobs to come back
they wanted somebody to care about them
even if they didn't live by one of the
[ __ ] oceans
you stupid [ __ ] white privilege white
go [ __ ] yourself you're doing better
than 99.999 percent of [ __ ] white
people in this country
you live in two mansions in l.a and you
get to [ __ ] make these videos
[ __ ] done and look at you in [ __ ]
1980 south beach
go [ __ ] yourself seriously it's a fact
you know what's a fact you're a hack you
know what's a fact your show was so
worthless it could be off the air for
one year
and nobody gave a flying [ __ ] you know
it's a fact that nba nbc executives
were sitting there and they're going
look we have our back against the wall
we couldn't push this bisexual woman of
power
and now [ __ ] now cancel her so we're
going to revamp the entire show we're
going to fire entire writings
squad and everything you know what you
are you're that
you're one you know when a team fires
all the players but keeps a head coach
because they paid him too much
that's what you are your time is coming
lily it's going to come
and it's not going to be white supremacy
that puts you down it's going to be
your uh your aggressive amount
your aggressive lack of talent
is why you're gonna go away you stupid
talentless i gotta disagree here
you know i just think that um white's
clearly a problem and
look i blame trump personally because
the platinum plan
wasn't big enough and i've been saying
that from day one that you know 500
billion dollars for black owned
businesses is nothing
i think if trump had given him something
like like we like ts now we like
trillions people like the word trillion
i think trump should have given black
people
a trillion dollars and then i think that
that would have been able to uh win over
these people
and i think we would have won i i think
that's where trump came up short
500 social media accounts finally
stepped up and
locked the president's accounts because
he was inciting violence and hate but
also i'm just like
stepped up they stepped up this
pro-censorship they stepped up
do you remember when they were [ __ ]
censoring music artists and like [ __ ]
twisted sister and all these [ __ ]
people came out in the in front of the
center like
you can't censor us we have the right to
say what we want let me ask you a
[ __ ] question
if we were singing if they were singing
that this country's falling apart would
it be okay if we were doing a [ __ ]
hip-hop
[ __ ] song about it would it be fine
go [ __ ] yourself the pres
stepped up shut the [ __ ] up this divided
this country
you just called 70 million people white
supremacist
how is that not dividing the country
i [ __ ] hate her what took you so long
but then that got me to think
why is social media finally changing and
it is because
a beautiful thing happened people have
really
really understood now that standing
together and standing up for something
does make a difference
censorship good is what you're saying
standing together
and standing up for something as long as
it's what you believe in
but the other people that [ __ ] that
feel left out the other people that feel
that they don't know how they're gonna
[ __ ] feed their families
standing together going hey this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] why are we doing the
platinum plan like you mentioned why are
we doing the platinum plan
what about us who can't feed their fans
oh okay i see
so it's standing you could stand up and
come together about something you
believe
as long as you're not [ __ ] white i
got it lily censorship
good i you know i was fun making fun of
you but i hope
you fail i hope that you blow all your
money in some sort of ponzi scheme
and you're living on the streets of
[ __ ] bombay her family's probably got
money
yeah and i gotta give a huge shout out
to the black community because you have
inspired so many other communities to
band together
yeah we know you like the black
community because you do [ __ ] black
mouth all the time
let me ask you so if i were to if i were
to do an entire show i was like
yo dawg what's up man my what's up my
dude
the black community would be like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you why are you
talking like that
you're in every youtube video of yours
and remember she even talked about it
the way she talks because she's from the
streets of toronto she's from the
streets of toronto everyone's [ __ ]
hood
no but that's okay you could do [ __ ]
black mouth
all you want and that's fine the thing
is you're not self-aware lily
you're not self-aware you're just a
[ __ ] it's not a
because she's indian but you're whatever
version of that that is
speak up you're seeing it in the farmer
protest as many people are protesting
the treatment of farmers in india
we also saw when people are protesting
the military conflict between armenia
and azerbaijan
we see that we can make a difference if
we stand together
and i love that yeah yeah yeah that
really worked out well for armenia huh
worked out super good for them huh this
worked out super well for them huh
i want this show to be all about love
and delight
i want the show to be all about love and
light but i'm going to tell 70 million
people
that they're [ __ ] white supremacist
she doesn't even realize now she has to
realize it
don't listen you can show could be
whatever about you want it's your show
i don't care what your show's about but
don't [ __ ] sit there with a straight
face and tell me you're uniting people
okay because you're not the otherness
and positivity okay and i hope you're on
board and if you're not you can yell at
me on twitter
i just won't see it for a while low and
light everybody knows you won't see it
for a while but you know what you will
see you will see when we clip this and
we put it on youtube
because lily's seeing that we've learned
this by the way lily singh is the type
of person who googles her name
every single day lily's singing is
somebody who has a google alert for her
name
you're going to see it lily you're going
to see this video she's seen our videos
you're going to see this video and
you're going to realize you're a
disingenuous person
and by the way lily before you talk
about white
i'm a [ __ ] so you got go [ __ ] yourself
i hope your show fails i hope all your
endeavors fail
and i hope we get to a place in the
world where i know may it might it
may be our youtube channel gets wiped
but i hope we get to a place where
something you say becomes controversial
and they take away your youtube channel
too
and then we're gonna sit there and we're
all gonna be laughing from trove or
whatever new alternative
about how you got [ __ ] by the very
system because i've said
this before and people say it all the
time you could pander to the mob
all you want the mob might eat you last
but they will eat you wait till you
start getting canceled
for the way you talk and appropriating
black culture it's a common lily
it's a [ __ ] comment shows about love
i'm like in fact you know i'm not asking
what is the show love and light watch
check this out i just
unscripted yo ileana what is this this
is scripted
stressful
huh huh lily sing everybody
she's fantastic